[Music]
[Music]
we've been alongside this cast from the
very beginning like before they could
even get the show's name right now it's
called a 99 100 and 902 100 that it goes
5 years that it beats cheers wow what a
sweet little baby I was only just hope
it goes I mean what was that voice like
I don't even I don't even recognize that
voice anymore we were there when Jason
made his directorial debut on the show
he's been calling shots ever since we're
all my husband's lovely nice but sort of
get to look into his eyes and stare at
us but a lot and it makes us want to do
a really good job
did we flash back to this and this guy
and this is you talking about Lou I said
look do you surf
he said no he said the you I said not a
stitch and I looked at him and I said
we're gonna get along just fine I
remembered that that night that I met
Luke incredibly clearly when we read
that first grip the greenroom described
I remember that night he came and he
said man they won't give me a contract
they said they ain't gonna have to see
if it works out I hope I get to keep
this job
[Music]
we were even there for the 100th episode
and the final episode for what's always
stood out to us about this cast is it's
undeniable love for one another well you
guys were supposed to film it I want to
show you this uh-huh
it just makes you laugh when you it's
kind of hard to picture this as a
business when you're really working with
guys who are like brothers nothing's
changed nothing's changed
know what it was what would you say to
that guy I would say you were right yeah
all right this does feel like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]